time for our first guest and he's been a
frequent guest this Detroit native broke
the hearts of everyone in his home state
by choosing Notre Dame over Michigan and
they've never forgotten it
he went on a 13 year NFL run with the
ramps and the Steelers participated in
Super Bowl 44 Pittsburgh where he had a
great view of Willie Parker running for
a long touchdown his self-proclaimed
greatest athletic achievement is bowling
a 300 his louis athletic achievement was
losing to me in a footrace before Super
Bowl 43 please welcome the boss
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
gonna take you a little while to get up
here you're so slow I can't believe this
guy didn't you like that introduction
you know what you are a pessimist a
pessimist like everything you say is
negative everything you say is negative
I mean my hall-of-famer like last that's
what the last thing you say you want a
Super Bowl you had a great view of you
know the other running back that's just
the fact that's the back side of the see
you the other part of it did you know in
first and I was in the greenroom
what and I'm listening to this about
this race and you're lucky I can't curse
because I would curse him out because
that would make you german curse here's
a problem he is he it's embellished a
lot more now I mean this is just this
thing nap first of all he talks about
excuses I had on dress shoes you had on
gym shoes okay that was one he says he's
then he wanted a seven-yard head start
right he's he's talking about and he
said he beat me by 10 how would he know
if he's running you felt comfortable you
should have needed the head start but
you you fought me for the head start you
know what I did have you ever seen like
when Usain Bolt runs and he looks at the
jumbotron
I was running looking at the jumbotron
10 yards ahead of him if he saw me on
the jumbotron there will be footage of
this race ok do you believe believe the
Tony Dungy tells the truth do you
believe the Tony Dungy here's what I'll
say about Tony Dungy in all of his years
of coaching he has lied before he has
I mean like his players or something he
said something that maybe has been a one
truth Wow I don't think he's not I mean
he's a truthful person but he's probably
given a little bit of a fib in there
somewhere do you think that Bob Costas
the esteemed journalist would lie about
the results of that race I do not have
Bob Casas on the record saying that you
expanded your 7-yard headstart
he's not on the record saying that we
mother Teresa was also there that day
now are you gonna call mother Teresa
alive if you look at her life and for
totality okay alright former Steeler
running back the great the guy who came
up with throwing somebody under the bus
thank you I did not know that you came
up with that saying wait you didn't know
you did see I was trying to be positive
are you okay
I'm great now okay that you've been
exposed he rushed for thirteen thousand
yards ninety four touchdowns and he won
a Super Bowl yeah he's your own baddest
[Applause]
now can we have a fruitful conversation
why why aren't the Steelers here ah
dysfunction oh ok where does dysfunction
start it starts at the top
obviously in you know coaches but not
ownership well it always starts at the
top
ownership has been obviously allowed for
this to happen
so everybody has to take blame I think
that's where the problem starts if
nobody wants to take blame then it's a
problem so I think from an ownership
standpoint they've taken blame they've
done some things to to now try to
correct it they've they've maybe fire
some guys and coaches some coaches that
coach Tomlin would have not under
enormous normal circumstances let go
what Bill Cowher
have handled it differently he would
have handled it differently I think but
from the beginning because coach Tomlin
what he did was an admirable thing in
terms of allowing these guys a little
space allowing them to police themselves
in the locker room those type of things
and those are some of the things that
that coach Cowher allowed but at the end
of the day he made the call on a lot of
those things so he didn't leave a lot of
wiggle room for guys where coach kind of
allow aligning wiggle room and because
of it it's a new day and age he's kind
of allowed other things to transpire
that Coach would have not allowed to
transpire so as a result coach you know
Tomlin has to take a shoulder a lot of
the blame because he allowed that
environment
well what bothered you more Le'Veon Bell
or Antonio Brown what bothered me more
is maybe on bail neither side working it
out I thought it was it was imperative
that both sides work through it because
it was only going to benefit both the
organization would benefit because he
incredible football player but he would
benefit because you had a great
offensive line you had a complement of
receivers you got a great quarterback
you had everything that would allow you
to have four or five six more years of
outstanding success and now you start
looking at the other things Super Bowls
championships and then you know possibly
a Hall of Fame type career would you
want a Antonio Brownback if you were on
the Steelers that's a tough one I say
yes but it's not it's not that easy yes
but you have to change him but I can't
change now it's not impossible it's not
probable but he's a wide receivers not a
path he's used to getting a hundred
catches they're all divas you got an
emerging star in juju Smith Schuster
yeah and it felt like there was a
disconnect between you know Antonio
Brown and Ben Roethlisberger there was
something there that we don't know right
so clearly there was a problem but do
you think that Ben actually went to the
line of scrimmage call to play and then
said you know what I'm not looking for
Antonio Brown I don't think because
Antonio Brown was open one time for a
touchdown and Ben missed it right but I
don't know if Ben's gonna go boy this
I'm gonna hold this grudge and I'm not
gonna throw it to you in practice yeah I
don't think it was that significant it
was probably from a different set of
lenses you know he's saying I'm open
receivers always think they're open
you've been in the huddle when those
guys come back what do they say just
throw it throw it and they're never
opened and then you look at the film and
you know you weren't covered so but but
there was a there is a a disconnect
there that I think you got a straight
now but if I am if I'm the organization
now you're in a difficult situation
because the other teams if you're going
to trade for him then the team is that
trina's trade form is gonna say
it's fools go because although it looks
like it's a three year do that looks
like it can work once I give the
students the first-round pick and a
third round or right but I'm just saying
let's just say he was or third round
pick Freddie Tony okay but then the
minute you trade for for me now I say I
need a new country and so now these
organizations may not want to trade for
this guy so now what you have to look at
the possibility of no not the interest
not being there right are you not
getting what you deserve
you think you deserve for his talents
and I think that's when you have to say
synonyms send a letter we'll see you
August for training camp or beginning
into July we'll see you in August
get ready that's it right here's the
parameters if you don't show up you
won't be find here and lay out
everything that you expect and then at
that point if he if he shows up he
understands if he doesn't show up he's
fine and that's how you have to leave it
he's Jerome Bettis the sixteenth year of
the FedEx air and ground NFL players of
the Year awards recognizing top
quarterback running back performances of
the season voting is open and will close
this Thursday at 3:00 Eastern winners
will be announced at NFL honors that
will be on Saturday fans can vote on NFL
Twitter page and nfl.com / FedEx the
nominees drew brees Patrick mahomes
Philip Rivers on the ground Zeke Elliott
Todd Gurley and say Quan Barkley where
is the running back position headed in
the NFL well I just had to put it into
one but there's 40 thousand dollar
donation nothing that the USO is gonna
receive from FedEx because in lieu of
the two winners that's going to go to a
project program called Pathfinder which
they it's the idea is to give the the
servicemen or spouses an opportunity to
to kind of react limit into civilian
life and they
actually help with that it's a very
important yes thanks
but the running back the running back
you know position I think everybody
thought that it was it was yeah you
don't need that running back you know
you to platoon him now but what we found
was that it was never that there was not
those type of players available right so
you have to get two guys to do one job
but now you know you got the influx of
these of these franchise running backs
so now that is it's gone that whole
thought that you need multiple guys is
going through the window because each
year you've gotten franchise type
running backs in the say quanta Barclays
if you're Elliott girly but how does
would you be if you came out now I
wouldn't be that much how many pencils
did you catch in your career I didn't
catch well because the offense wasn't
designed for me to catch did not look
for you the way he didn't look for
Antonio is no now you tell me what this
is looking at see I read into it
different like he played quarterback now
he knows what the quarterback is
thinking right I did play quarterback my
freshman year in high school I played
quarterback I know the position it's a
reason you didn't write it is a reason
you didn't play your sophomore year yeah
we've seen enough I retired a year and
then I devoted my life to torching the
school's Clinton Massey and a Springboro
and you know Kingsmill you know google
it I torched him like I retired as a
retired and I just said this is my
life's mission what was your guys record
your freshman year it really wasn't
about it's about teamwork it's just
about come
during and getting to know each other at
some point you got is a winner loss
subway I think we might have been three
and six or something like that but but
you know those six losses were by a
combined like 70 points or so so I know
the position you just say I played one
year and I think that's enough okay okay
okay yeah well no the offense is when I
was playing
they weren't geared around getting the
running back to ball out in space now on
third down we would have a third down
back come in and they would have passes
for the running back on third downs but
the the evolution of the game has
changed so much so now the running back
is key in terms of creating a mismatch
and I think that's that's really in part
to the Patriots because they're they're
the team that really said you know what
we're going to get more out of the
running back position in space because
we believe our running back is going to
be better than your linebacker and
you're not gonna be able to cover them
and until that point that was never
really exposed that much but the
Patriots they make a living out of doing
that so now every team says our running
back has to be able to catch the
football because there's an advantage
there if we can if we can utilize I
think it was 10 years ago Paulie when we
were down in Miami Miami and bus he was
there and I think you guys tried to
tackle yes yeah that was about 10 years
ago yeah we have a situation though what
we were looking for the footage of it
and it is nowhere to be found
yeah someone destroyed it I was sabotage
again you know whenever something good
happens to me it gets lost or it was
destroyed they can't find it right I
pushed him we can't find the video of me
beating you in a footrace so who
destroyed that bus it was no you told
the guy don't film it because you were
scared that it was going to be so
terrible that you didn't want them to
have it on record
file we don't have we don't have footage
we looked all over for and he really you
know it's funny cuz we thought Jerome
was gonna run right through us and he
went ship shift and was gone he's gonna
have wheels and Lucy yes
that's your estimation for your rose
colored lenses that you look for like do
you want to have a redo not not the
40-yard dash no no I I won't do that to
you but but when's the last time you ran
somebody over I have not not have not
ran anybody over in awful long time do
you miss it
no oh you know why because it doesn't
hurt then but the next day it does hurt
yeah but imagine how they felt right
they they heard that day I asked him one
time I said did you ever hear somebody
that you're that's tackling you like cry
[Applause]
cuz they when you're coming tighten up
[Laughter]
okay during the live look in I'm gonna
let you run the football against my guys
I mean if you want to unless you're
afraid of those guys
terrible why am i terrible I'm giving
you one last chance at glory well I was
sitting in the green room McLovin mother
yeah is in the room and she specifically
said don't thank you that this was gonna
happen she said do not hurt my okay so
and I'm under a firm direct no no but
paulie's mom is not here and she doesn't
care and she does
the care feed gets hurt so let's see
it's great to see you doing great things
with FedEx the air and ground NFL player
of the year awards and it'll be they'll
close the voting Thursday at 3:00
Eastern and FedEx will make a $20,000
donation to the USO in the name of both
winning quarterback and running back
will come back will get to our play of
the day
bus will run over Pauley right after
this here's what we got okay so this is
from Miami ten years ago it's we're
trying we're trying everything okay
everything all right I guess we're gonna
have the reenact okay all right so it's
not it says you know connected okay
no got nothing gonna all right so that
means who wants to try to attack the bus
I think we got it let me live the old
days all right that'd be a problem
yeah first of all I'll sign a waiver we
got to make sure from from a healthcare
perspective you know we can make sure
these guys know I'm fine because I've
known the hurts of life I'm fully
insured I've been known to hurt if
something if Paulie gets hurt a variety
of place in a verbal way as long as it's
on camera I need to make sure that
somebody's looking at his eyes because
at the moment of impact that tells you
if you really wanted it that okay maybe
we could have the cameraman over here oh
oh here we go
we got you running oh we got it okay
here we go
so this is Paulie let's see and seaton I
drove through this hop step like I know
what you didn't want to he didn't want
to take the contact I was trying to save
these guys okay so look at a little seat
and Paulie yeah
look at that you look like you're in
pretty good shape yeah yeah alright this
will be better than see in this out you
scared by the way you've talked to him
yeah you're a guy you take his head off
it works
oh look at those little guys right soon
they start getting nervous a little bit
even there okay here we go
[Laughter]
feather yeah and now you freeze and
that's when I run yo and I don't even
well you make contact but you don't have
any so we can come here and I go boom
and then now when I go this goggle this
now
but usually Denis coming up I don't want
to hurt you so you would run so if so I
would so we've just hop here I would
come here and I would come up through
this init with an e he go down yeah yeah
so I give him the shoulder and then the
knee he's an Isis but that's why they
would just go right at your feet he
meant that in Realty you had two choices
or you try to grab get it yeah I go back
Oh hold on thank you very much for being
thank you thank you hey thank you Joe
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]